PIERRE LECESNE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Pierre, and I'm a Software
Engineer on Google Play.
ANTHONY MORRIS: Hi, everyone.
I'm Anthony, also a Software
Engineer on Google Play.
IBRAHIM KARAHAN: And I'm
Ibo, a Partner Developer Advocate at Google.
PIERRE LECESNE:
Well, some of you
might just be coming
from the previous session
at the amphitheater, which
gave an overview of Google Play
Dynamic Delivery and its
new publishing format
called the Android
App Bundle and how
this will make apps smaller.
In this session, we will
do a technical deep dive
on this new publishing format.
We will cover what it
contains, how to build it,
how to publish it, but also the
different ways you can test it.
We'll also cover how Google
Play generates and serves
the APKs to end users.
So let's start with the format
of the Android App Bundle.
The Android App Bundle
is a zip archive.
It contains the files
you're already familiar
with in APKs, such as text files
and with resources, assets,
native libraries.
It's important to realize that
the app bundle and the APK
are two distinct formats
with two different purposes.
The app bundle is a purely
a publishing format,
so it cannot be directly
installed on a device.
It also contains
some metadata files
that don't end up in
the final APKs, that
just help the tools build
the APKs the right way.
Finally, the format of the app
bundle is stricter than APK.
We want to ensure that
the tools can fully
understand the
files in the bundle
so that they can
generate valid APKs.
Now let's open up one app bundle
and look at what's inside.
So if you open that bundle,
this is what you should expect.
So this should look
familiar to a lot of people.
Instead of
reinventing the wheel,
we decided to reuse some
of the structure of APKs
and only modify what we needed
to better describe the files.
So we'll be free
to go through them.
To start with,
the app bundle has
support for having
multiple modules,
as you may have heard before.
And we'll tell you more
about module shortly.
For now, just know that
the top-level directories
in the app bundle are
the names of the modules.
There is always a module
named base in the module,
in the bundle.
And that's the one
we're looking at here.
The Android manifest
is still present.
New project is a real XML file.
In the APKs, you may
notice a binary format.
In the app bundle, it's
compiled into a protocol buffer
format, which allows us to
transform it more easily.
As opposed to APK,
the dex files are
under a directory named dex.
The Android
resources, the assets,
and the negative libraries,
on the other hand,
follow the same directory
structure as in an APK.
The only difference
are the XML resources,
which are also compiled into
a protocol buffer format,
instead of the binary format.
The file resources.pb
is the resource table.
It's the equivalent of
the file resources.arac
that you may have
seen in your APKs.
It describes the resources
present in your app
and the targeting.
The .pb extension-- it's in a
protocol buffer format, which,
again, makes it easier for
tools to transform it before
it's converted into its
binary form in the APK.
The assets.pb and
native.pb files
are the equivalent of the
resource table for assets
and native libraries.
So they only exist if you have
asset or native libraries,
and they also describe
the targeting of the files
in their respective directories.
As I've mentioned before,
the resource table,
the asset table, and the
native libraries table
describe the targeting
of the files of your app.
So let me explain
what I mean by that.
File targeting is
the description
of what type of device or user
a given file is targeted for.
It's a central concept in
Google Play dynamic delivery,
since understanding
the targeting of files
means we can serve to a given
user only the files they need.
And this is what allows
us to make apps smaller.
The app bundle reuses the
targeting that exists in APKs.
You're already
familiar with this,
so I'll just go and
run through it quickly.
For resources, you
specify, for example,
HDPI in the directory
name of your resource
to target HDPI devices, or you
add fr to target French users.
For native libraries,
it's the same.
You add the architecture
to the directory.
Again, nothing new here.
The app bundle
works the same way.
Now we realize that
for some of you,
assets represent a
big part of your app.
So the app bundle also
supports assets targeting.
We're starting with
language targeting,
and we will soon be adding
texture compression formats
and graphics API versions.
So we can serve only the
relevant assets to the users
and reduce further the size
of your apps and games.
This is how you would create
a targeted asset directory.
While making use
of the hash sign
to identify an asset
directory that has targeting,
then comes the key
which defines which
dimensions we are
targeting-- for example,
lang for the language, tcf for
texture compression formats,
et cetera.
And then comes the value
associated with a key.
Well, let's see some examples.
Here's an example of a
directory containing assets
for users speaking French.
This is another example
of an asset directory,
targeted based on the texture
compression format here,
targeting devices that
support the format etc1.
Now that you know more
about the app bundle format,
I'll hand it over
to Anthony, who
will tell you how we use this
to serve smaller apps to users.
ANTHONY MORRIS :
Thanks, Pierre.
Hi, everyone.
So Pierre was just
explaining to you
how we're changing
the format of what
you publish to the Play Store.
And now I'm going
to explain to you
how we're changing the format
of what we serve to users,
and how we use this
to deliver only
what is needed for each user.
Now, we start with split APKs.
So in Android Lollipop, we
added a feature to the Android
platform called split APKs.
Split APKs allow multiple APKs
to be installed on a device
and behave as if they
were part of a single app.
These split APKs
can be installed
in different combinations
on different devices,
and they can be installed in one
go up front or piece by piece.
Now, a split APK has the
same format as a normal APK.
They can contain Java code index
files, native code, resources,
and assets directories.
And once split
APKs are installed,
these can all be accessed as
if they were in a single APK.
And furthermore,
each application
has the same package
name and version
code with all the
other ones that
are installed on the
device, and that must all
be signed with the same key.
So now, let's take a look at
how we can take the Android App
Bundle and generate split APKs
that we then serve to devices.
So we start by looking
in the app bundle
and finding everything that
is common to all the devices
and putting them in a base APK.
So this would include
the Android manifest file
and the dex files, for instance.
Then we generate a
different split APK
for each screen density.
Each split will contain
all the durables
that would have been selected
by the Android framework
on a device with that density.
We can also generate
a different split APK
for each native architecture
containing native libraries
of that architecture.
And we can generate
a different split
for each language
supported by your app,
putting each language's
strings in a different APK.
Now, together, we call
these splits configurations
splits or config splits.
Now, when we go to serve
an app to a device,
we only need to serve a
subset of these splits,
instead of serving
everything to every device.
So say I have a
Samsung Galaxy J5.
We will install the base APK,
as well as the xhdpi density
split, the ARM architecture
split, and the English language
split, because I
only speak English.
But it can get a bit
trickier than that.
Pierre speaks both
French and English,
and he specifies both of
those languages in his device
settings.
So in his device, a Pixel
2 XL, in addition to
the right density
and architecture
splits, we will serve both the
French and the English language
split to his device.
Now, suppose Pierre then
moves to Brazil and learns
Portuguese.
He might then add Portuguese
as a language on his device.
Now, when he does
this, the Play Store
recognizes this and will attempt
to download the Portuguese
language split for all apps
that use splits on the device.
And if the device is
not online at the time,
then we will download
those language
splits at the next opportunity.
And so that's how
config splits work.
But as I mentioned
at the start, splits
are only supported on
Lollipop and above.
This covers about 85% of users
at the moment, but most of you
still target pre L
devices, which is great.
And for these devices,
the app bundle
still allows us to achieve
some of the size savings
by generating standalone APKs
containing specific densities
and architectures.
So instead of generating splits,
as we would do for L plus,
we would generate this
matrix of standalone APKs.
We briefly considered
extending this to language
splits as well, but we
did some of the sums,
and it got a little
bit out of hand.
But now, for Pre
L devices, we have
to include all the languages
in each of the standalone APKs.
Now when we go to
serve the app, we
choose the best single
APK for your device.
So if we have my first Android
device-- a Galaxy Nexus--
we would serve the hdpi
arm standalone APK.
You might recognize
this because this
is similar to what
you may have done
in the past with multi APK.
But let's put this all together.
The picture looks like
this, and you actually
don't actually need to worry
about the details about how
all these split
APKs are generated
or standalone APKs
are generated.
All you have to do is
upload a single app bundle,
and then Play generates the
right splits and selects
the right ones to
serve for each device.
And the dimensions
we've discussed so far
are only the beginning.
Pierre discussed how the app
bundle lets you target assets
by graphics API, and we will
soon generate config splits
based on that.
We'll also start
generating config
splits to take advantage
of new platform features.
And we'll start with supporting
uncompressed native libraries
on m-class devices.
Now I'll ask Ibo
to come up to take
a look at how much we can reduce
app size by using this app
bundle.
IBRAHIM KARAHAN:
Thank you, Anthony.
Now that we know how Play serves
split APKs to your devices,
we're going to talk about the
size savings with app bundles.
We found out that, on average,
apps published with app bundles
are 20% smaller, and that
is 20% savings every time
your application is
downloaded or upgraded.
Now let's look at how
we reached this number.
We analyzed all the
applications in Play Store
with more than one
million downloads.
And we found out
that for strings, we
can save over 95% of their size
by using the language splits.
For images, this is 45%.
And for native libraries, we
can save 20% of their sizes.
This means if every app
were to move to app bundles,
we would save approximately
10 petabytes of data per day
from app downloads and updates.
That is 10 million gigabytes,
or 300 million music videos
on YouTube.
And on top of that, users
could see an extra 300 megabyte
of disk space for more photos,
more apps, or more music
on their devices.
So now let's look at
actual size savings
that are some of our early
access program and partners.
So we're going to
start with Twitter.
Twitter-- we're already
publishing with multi APKs
before with architecture splits.
However, their
application is translated
into a lot of languages, and
it supports multiple screen
densities.
They still get lots of
savings with publishing
with app bundles, which is
20% increase in the size.
Plus, they don't have to
serve with multi APKs anymore.
The next one is TextPlus, which
wasn't using multi APKs before.
With app bundles--
26% size savings across all
dimensions with app bundles.
Jaumo's app is half
of its original size,
and this is because they have
a large [INAUDIBLE] library.
And they supported multiple
architectures in a single APK.
Now let's look at how we
can build an app bundle,
and you can start saving now.
The latest Android
Studio 3.2 Canary
has full support for
Android app bundles.
Now we're going to see
a new option to build
a bundle in the Build menu.
[INAUDIBLE] everything assigned
app bundle is easy as well.
We're going to just select your
app module, product flavor,
and build type,
and Android Studio
is going to create an app
bundle for you'll, sign,
which is ready for publishing.
For those who
prefer command line
or wish to integrate with
automated build systems,
the new Gradle Android plugin
provides a new set of tasks
to build Android app bundles.
Just remember, this is what
you use-- the assemble task
on the command line
to create the APK.
Now for app bundles,
you're going
to switch to the bundle command.
Similar to the assemble
tasks, bundle tasks
also allow you to
build a specific flavor
of your application.
Once the bundle
task finishes, it's
going to create an app
bundle in the output folder,
with the flavor and
the build type chosen.
The built architect
is called bundle.iad.
Bundle tasks are compatible
with the signing configs
in your build.gradle files.
And with a single
gradle task, you
can produce app
bundles that are signed
and ready for publishing.
And also, with app bundles,
Play will automatically
split your application into
architecture, screen density,
and language splits
by default. You
don't need to do
any configurations.
However, we also
want our developers
to have full control
over their splits.
So if for any reason you would
like to disable splitting
by any dimension, you can do so
by using the newly introduced
bundle block here.
Now Pierre's going to talk
about how to publish your app
bundle in the Play Console.
PIERRE LECESNE: Thanks, Ibo.
All right, so you have
built an app bundle.
Now let's look at how
you can publish it
on Google Play Console.
First, you must enroll in
App Signing by Google Play.
For those who remember,
we launched this program
at Google I/O last year.
When enrolling, you securely
transfer your release key
to Google Play.
Play then uses this
release key to sign
the generated APKs
on your behalf
before sending them to users.
But note that if you
keep uploading APKs
on your production
tap track, when
you test the app bundle
in the test track,
Play will not resign
the uploaded APKs.
And we did this so
you can feel confident
trying the app bundle on
a small audience first,
without affecting your
current production users.
Once you're enrolled, you
can manage your releases,
just like you did for APKs.
Create a new release--
drop the app bundles in the same
location, where you currently
drop APKs and wait
for the upload.
Once uploaded, you can review
your release and release out.
That's it.
And I can't stress this enough--
No more multi APKs to deal with.
Play Console has created,
in the background,
all the APKs for the
supported devices for you.
Now you have uploaded
your app bundle,
and Play has done all the
heavy lifting for you--
great.
But wouldn't it be nice to
be able to have an overview
of what Play has generated?
Well, we have built a
new tool in Play Console
called Bundle Explorer.
Bundle Explorer lets you
navigate your uploaded bundles.
Let's have a look.
On the first screen, you can
see at the top right corner
the size savings you gain
by publishing a bundle.
Here we saved over a
quarter of your app.
Of course, this is
different by device.
So we calculated this using a
popular device configuration.
You will also find below the
list of device configurations
and the total size of the
APK service to those devices.
Can even click on a few
devices and see which
devices are in each bucket.
You can even search for any
supported device by name
to download the set of
generated APKs that is
served to that specific device.
This will be super
helpful when you
get that bug report on
that specific device,
and you want to get exactly
what the user has gotten
and what APKs were served.
So you just search for
the name, click Download,
and you'll get the set of
APKs that Play has served.
Of course, we haven't
forgotten all of you
who use our publishing API.
Uploading app bundles is also
available using our API today.
You will find all
the documentation
at developers.google.com/android
publisher.
And now, hand it
over to Anthony.
ANTHONY MORRIS:
Thanks, Pierre.
So we've now learned
how to build and publish
an Android app bundle.
But before we
finalize a release,
we'd still like to
do a round of tests.
However, we've seen that
the app bundle on its own
is not installable.
So how do you test it?
First, we know that
during development, you
can install APKs
built from the app
directly from Android Studio.
So you don't need
to do anything here.
However, for QA teams, we
know that they don't always
have access to the source
code in Android Studio.
So let me talk you through the
story of three developers--
Alice, Bob, and Clare--
and how they choose to test
their app bundle with their QA
items.
So let's start with Alice.
Alice uses the newly
released internal test
track from the Play Console.
The internal track is
similar to alpha beta tracks,
that you may already
be familiar with.
But it differs in that
there is almost no delay
between the upload of
the bundle and the update
being available on
the tester's device--
really quick turnaround
for your QA testing.
Going through the
Play Console, Alice
has the confidence that what
the QA team will receive
on their device is byte
to byte equal with what
end users will get when you
push your release to production.
And let's see how
Alice sets this up--
really simple.
So Alice creates a list of
emails of up to 100 QA testers
that are eligible for
the internal test track.
Her QA testers follow
the update link
and then now receive the
bundles that are uploaded
to the internal test track.
That's it.
But we know that not all of you
have access to the Play Console
during your QA cycles.
So let's hear from
Pierre about Bob's story.
PIERRE LECESNE:
Indeed, Bob doesn't have access
to the Play Console.
He prefers also to test
things locally on his machine
before uploading
anything, but he still
wants to test what
the users will get.
So how does he do that?
Well, to generate
APKs from the bundle,
Play uses a new tool
called Bundletool.
So for Bob to reproduce
locally the builds,
he can simply download
Bundletool and write
a few simple commands.
Bundletool has a command
called Build APKs, which
takes an Android app
bundle and creates
what we call an APK set archive.
An APK set contains
a collection of APKs
ready to be
installed on devices.
Another command
called install APKs
takes that APK set
archive, extracts the APKs,
and install them on that device.
Let's see some real
command line work.
So here's the command
[? recent ?] by Bob
calling build-apks,
passing the app bundle,
and saying where he wants
the APK set to be created.
And by passing the
flag-connected device,
Bundletool will build APKs
just for the device currently
connected to his machine.
And if Bob wants
to generate APKs,
say, for someone else on
his team without having
the physical device
at hand, it can still
provide a file that
contains the specifications
of the device in a JSON format.
And you can see here an
extract of such file, which
provides the information about
the APIs this device supports,
supported languages, the screen
density, and the APK version.
Bundletool has also come in to
generate such device spec file.
So you don't have to find
the device spec online,
or you don't have to
write it yourself.
You just run this
command, and it will
generate this file for you.
Also, because Bob wants
to install these APKs
on the device, the APKs need to
be signed with a private key.
So he passes the
path to the keystore.
All the APKs contained
in the APK set
will then be signed and directly
installable on Bob's device.
And here's the invocation of
the install APKs command, which
extracts the APKs
from the APK set
and installs them directly
on the connected device--
easy.
So that was Bob and
his local testing.
Now Ibo will tell
you Claire's story.
IBRAHIM KARAHAN:
Claire's working
for a medium-sized
company, and they
set up a continuous integration
tool to fill their application.
Every day, the QA
team pulls a nightly
build of the application,
installs in multiple devices,
and tests if the application
is working correctly.
Claire wants to
help the QA team,
and she uses the
Bundletool again
to generate the
APK set in the CI.
She uses a command that's
very similar to what
Bob used earlier.
But this time, she omits
the device spec flag,
and she generates an
APK set, which contains
APKs for all possible devices.
Now the QA team will just
grab APK set from the CI.
They're going to
connect the device
and run the
install-apks command.
Bundletool then will read
the device configuration
from the attached
device, will extract
APKs that matches this
configuration from the APK set,
and then install
them onto the device.
This is the same
selection that Play
does when serving APKs
for a given device.
One more thing that
Bundletool can do
is to generate a universal APK
by passing the universal flag.
The universal APK is a single
APK that contains the file--
all the files for
all the devices.
Because of that, it can be
installed in any device.
Well, it really
doesn't represent
what your users
will receive when
they install the
application from Play Store.
However, this is a convenient
way to pass an APK to a user
when you don't know what
device they are running.
Bundletool is also the tool used
to build an Android App Bundle,
and Gradle uses it
behind the scenes.
We're going to
work with the other
build chains, toolchains,
to integrate build tool
so that you can build an
Android App Bundle, regardless
of any toolchain
you may be using.
And finally, we want to
be transparent about how
we generate the
APKs we delivered
to your users, which is why we
are open sourcing Bundletool.
You can go today to get
github.com/google/bundletool
to download an executable
or [? builded ?] it from
the source.
Now Pierre is going to
talk about another way
to make your applications
even smaller.
PIERRE LECESNE: Thanks, Ibo.
With Google Play
Dynamic Delivery,
we're also introducing
a new way to break up
your app into separate
features and deliver only those
that are needed for each user.
Suppose you have a
recipe app, and you
want to keep the
initial download small.
You observe that while
all your users like
to browse for recipes, only
a small fraction choose
to actually add a new recipe.
And you notice that this
functionality takes up
significant space in your app.
What you can do is break that
feature out into its own module
and serve it only when needed.
We can see how it
looks for user here.
Let's open the app.
And so when the user
wants to add the recipe,
he clicks on the little
plus at the bottom.
And you can see that
in the background,
the module is downloaded
and installed.
And just after a few seconds,
the module is ready to be used.
So which parts of
your app should you
break out as separate features?
If only a small fraction of
your users use that feature,
that could be a good
candidate, especially
if that feature takes up
significant space in your app.
Finally, consider if your
users can wait a few seconds
before using the feature.
Once you've decided
which feature to create,
this is how it should look
like in the app bundle.
In addition to the
base directory,
there are now also
separate directories
for each of the
modules of the app.
The format of these
directories is exactly
the same as the format of the
base that I covered earlier.
And this is the APKs that
Play would generate from it.
For each module, we will
produce a set of splits
consisting of a feature
split and config
splits for that module.
Anthony mentioned earlier that's
split APKS were only introduced
with Android Lollipop
to support 3L devices,
you can mark modules
to be refused,
and Bundletool will generate a
single APK with the specified
modules merged together.
Now that we have covered
how dynamic features work,
let me hand you over to
Ibo, who will show you
how to create them.
IBRAHIM KARAHAN: Thanks, Pierre.
To create a dynamic
module, all you need to do
is download Android
Studio 3.2 Canary
and use the dynamic
feature wizard included.
Click on the New
Module in File menu,
choose the dynamic module.
And so typing in your module's
name, Android Studio is going
is going to create a new
dynamic module for you.
You can also do the
same thing manually
by editing the manifest
and build.gradle files.
You're going to start with the
manifest of your new module.
The first step is to
declare this module
as a new split APK of your app.
To do so, you going to
add the split attribute
in the manifest tag
and give a name, which
is vrviewer in this example.
The next step is to add
the module tag, which
is going to declare a
module, and you're going
to give a title to the module.
This tag is used by Play
Store to identify the modules
of your application.
Next, you declare this
module as an on-demand module
by adding the
onDemand attribute.
This means that
this module is only
going to be delivered
to the user's device
when the app requests
it from the Play Store,
instead of delivering
it at install time.
Of course, we now know that
on-demand modules are only
supported on L plus devices.
So if you choose to also provide
this module in 3L devices,
you're going to
add the fusing tag
to instruct Play
Store to include
this module alongside the
base module at install time,
when delivering to 3L devices
or in the universal APK.
Now look at the
build.gradle files.
We're going to start
with the dynamic module.
The first thing is that we're
now using a new plugin called
com.android.dynamic-feature.
The second thing is
we add the base module
as a dependency to
this module so that we
can access the functionality
included in the base module.
The only change required in the
build.gradle file of the base
module is to add the
dynamic features list
and put all the dynamic
module names into this list.
This is to instruct gradle
to make the resources stored
in the base module available
to those dynamic modules.
Now Anthony is going to show you
how you can use those modules
with the new Play Core Library.
ANTHONY MORRIS: Thanks, Ibo.
So let's take a
look at how you go
about requesting on-demand
modules to be installed, when
you want them to be installed.
So in order to interact
with the Play Store,
we are introducing
a split install API
as part of a new library
called the Play Core Library.
Now the Play Core Library
is a Java client library
that communicates with the
Play to have IPC on the device.
And then the Play
Store communicates
with Play's servers to download
these on-demand modules when
you request them.
Let's take a look at
a bit of the code.
The API is structured using
the same task framework
that you're probably familiar
with from the Google Play
Services API and
FireBase APIs on Android.
Installation of splits is
coordinated by a class called
the splitInstallManager.
You construct a request
with all the models
that you wish to
download, and then
you invoke startInstall
to trigger the Play
to download the splits required
for those requested modules.
The API also allows
you to listen
for updates throughout the
download and install process.
You can use this to display
progress and download
progress in the install
progress to your users,
while they are waiting for the
on-demand feature to download.
You saw this in the
video that Pierre
showed when it was downloading
the address of the module.
For large modules, you'll need
to obtain user confirmation
prior to the download by
the split install API.
You'll need to do this
whenever the app requests
more than 10 megabytes
of on-demand modules
to be downloaded.
However, there is an
alternative option
for installing these modules,
which if they aren't required
immediately for immediate use,
and we call this the deferred
installation API.
If you use this simple one line
to request a deferred install
of a module, then
the module will
be downloaded at a
convenient time for the user.
This is generally
when the user is not
using the device, and its
charging in its own Wi-Fi.
And because of this, we allow
you to install larger modules
by the API, without
requiring user confirmation,
up to 100 megabytes.
So this is a really
user-friendly way
to download large on-demand
modules for your app.
You can also use the split
install API to manage
your on-demand modules.
So you can see which modules
are currently installed.
And if you user no
longer needs that module,
you can request for the
module to be uninstalled,
freeing up the precious
disk space for your users
and reducing the footprint
of your app on their device.
Now when you go and
install an on-demand module
on N Plus devices, the app
does not need to be restarted.
So the code is
available immediately
upon install completing and
new resources and assets
are available once you
refresh your context object.
However, on Android
L/M, installing splits
requires the app
to restart, if you
want to install them properly.
But to avoid this,
we've included
a split compact
library, which emulates
the installation
of a split on L/M
until the app goes
into the background
and we can properly install it.
And so this split
compact library
means that your app
doesn't need to restart,
and almost all the
things inside this module
are immediately
available to your app.
You can set this split
compact library up
in a very similar
way to how you might
be familiar with setting up the
Multidex library in your apps.
Finally, when you release
an update to your app,
Play will automatically
update both the base module
and any on-demand modules
that are already installed.
So the versions of your
modules that are on a device
are always in sync.
They're always at
the same version.
And partners tell us that this
is something that they really
like about this model.
All right, so let's
wrap this all up.
Starting today, all developers
can build Android App Bundles
in Android Studio 3.2 Canary.
And they'll be able to publish
these on Play to all users.
So I encourage all of you
to try this out and see
how much smaller your app
can be just by switching
to the Android App Bundle.
Now, we will be rolling
out modularization
to developers over
the coming months.
From today, you can start
building modularized apps
in the Studio Canary,
and you can publish them
to the internal and alpha
tracks within the Play console.
But we'll be opening up
publishing and production
tracks as a beta over
the coming months.
And if you're interested, you
can register your interest
in modularization at
the link provided.
And with that, thank you,
everyone, for coming.
If you have any questions,
you can grab us afterwards.
I don't think we
have time right now.
Or you can grab us over the next
couple of days in the Sandbox
C, just behind the stage.
And thank you.
Have a great I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]